we could have had JD Schulten in Iowa's
fourth congressional district but
instead incumbent lunatic outrageous
ideological disgusting neo-nazi white
nationalist associated Republican Steve
King was able to retain his seat in a
narrow win that got us to yesterday when
the house had a hearing where they
questioned Google CEO sundar pichai the
idea I guess was to explore bias and
search result sort of but the questions
were mostly uninformed and based in
vague conspiracy theories about Google
manipulating search results and a total
lack of practical technology knowledge
by the members of the committee and at
one point during these hearings Steve
King who again is a totally clueless guy
tied to white nationalists but one of
the worst Republicans in the House of
Representatives he angrily demanded
answers from Google CEO about how an
iPhone works which of course is not made
by Google it's made by Apple which is
actually sort of a competitor to Google
at least on some platforms there is so
much going on in the clip I'm about to
play for you that I want to prepare you
for it so number one you'll notice that
when Steve King asks this question to
sundar pichai he actually hesitates for
a second sundar does you can see him
weighing the options and debating in his
own mind do I give some kind of
diplomatic answer about how iPhones work
or do I treat this guy like The [ __ ]
that he is and explain that Google just
simply doesn't make the iPhone watch for
that crucial moment where you can see
him running through the possibilities in
his head you're also going to notice
that in the background of the video
there's someone dressed like the
monopoly guy like from the board game
Monopoly that's Ian Madrigal who has
shown up before at hearings dressed as
uncle Pennybags from monopoly to call
attention to the lobbying money that
floats around Congress so all of that
and more is happening in this clip let's
take a look I have a seven-year-old
granddaughter who picked up her phone
before the election and she's playing a
little game kind of game a kid would
play and up on there pops a picture of
her grandfather
and I'm not gonna say into their record
what the kind of language was used
around that picture of her grandfather
but I'd ask you how does that show up on
a seven-year-olds iPhone who's playing a
kids game
congressman iPhone is made by a
different company and so you know I mean
it might have been an Android it's just
it was a hand-me-down or some kind you
know I I guess I'm happy to follow up
and I understand the specifics it there
may be an application which was being
used which had a notification but I'm
happy to understand it better and
clarify it for you okay thank you for
your testimony and yield back the
balance of my time for sure this is just
just amazing and the defenders are
saying oh listen the question could have
applied to Android or iPhone it's such a
stupid question I mean quite frankly
it's such a stupid question and so
that's like the headline goofy
outrageous clip but there's actually
plenty of Democrats and Republicans
exposing how clueless they are about how
the internet works during this hearing
here's another one this is congressman
Lamar Smith a Republican from Texas he
asks Google's CEO to confirm that Google
has never punished anybody for
manipulating search results and Google's
CEO says no because no individual person
can do that take a look number two also
to my knowledge you've never sanctioned
any employee for any type of
manipulating the research results
whatsoever is that the case the time of
the gentleman has expired but mr. pitch
I will be allowed to answer question and
very quickly it's not possible for an
individual employee or groups of
employee to manipulate our search
results you know we have a robust
framework including many steps in the
process well and my time is up let me
just say I disagree I think humans can
manipulate the process is a human
process at his face Thank You mr.
chairman yield back
she recognized this is just the best
Lamar Smith disagrees he knows nothing
about anything but he disagrees his
feelings override the facts he feels
like individual employees can mess with
search results and he wants them
punished even though that's not how it
works
now of course I know in some broad sense
it's true right I mean humans made
Google so humans control how the
algorithm works but the idea that you'd
punish individuals for manipulating
search results is a bit silly and it
just shows how clueless Lamar Smith is
there are other clips if you want to see
more Steve King is a [ __ ] we know that
his constituents had a chance to vote
him out they opted to reelect him okay
the bigger picture from these hearings
is that it exposes that we have members
of Congress who don't know a thing about
technology in charge of figuring this
stuff out this is why instead of mostly
older lawyers and CEOs from industry we
need younger people we need people from
more diverse backgrounds scientists
people from more diverse professions
case in point we found out after
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham had
been on some tech committee maybe it was
cybersecurity don't remember exactly he
had been on this committee for a while
it was revealed that he had never sent
an email in his life Lindsey Graham 63
years old email has been around in some
form since he was 17 years old
admittedly it wasn't ubiquitous back
then but it's been around and commonly
used since Lindsey Graham was in his mid
30s Pat why does he have to be on a
cybersecurity or tech committee if he's
never even sent an email like is this
really the best that we can do this is
the best that we have like he said most
of these people are lawyers and they've
been politicians for decades so they
don't understand tech and it's not to
say that they can't ask tough questions
I think they can and they can press
these CEOs and make sure that they get
to the bottom of things but they should
do less grandstanding and more listening
at the end of the day yeah I mean just
the the questions expose how little they
understand about how things work and I'm
reminded of that law someone at one
point in New York State got off on child
porn charges because of how the raw law
was written just viewing child porn is
is not possessing it because you didn't
like right click save as to your
computer and this allowed people at
least one person potentially more to get
out of child porn
charges then they went in and changed
the law and it's this kind of reactive
situation we need on issues of
Technology and cybersecurity we need our
elected officials to be proactive you
can't be proactive unless you have some
understanding of what the hell is going
on however impressive it might be what
Barron Trump is doing with computers we
actually need our elected officials not
the children of presidents to be
knowledgeable informed and working for
us and proactively rather than seemingly
indifferent to how the real world
actually operates when it comes to these
technologies I mean just just
embarrassing in every way and hopefully
I mean the upside is that Steve Kings
cartoonish demand of sundar Pichai to
explain how an iPhone works even though
Apple makes iPhone not Google if it
serves the purpose of bringing this
hearing out into the open so more people
realize the degree of cluelessness that
our elected officials have on these
issues I would consider that a benefit a
net gain of Steve King saying really
dumb things today's program brought to
you in part by Blink accom slash Pakman
blinkie's is a great service that I use
all the time what they do is they take
thousands of the most popular
non-fiction books including the newest
bestsellers they condense them into
15-minute audiobooks that you can listen
to and you still get the most crucial
information and insights from each book
and I've listened to a ton of books on
blink Asst I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book of
BS jobs by David Graeber which I
listened to on blinka they're constantly
adding new books to the platform you
will never run out of fascinating and
critically acclaimed books to enjoy and
our audience can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink is comm slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube I'm
putting a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condemned
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
that's be Li NK is t.com /pa que mas